it's time for screen junkies boobie
bytes hoot-hoot where my owls at hashtag
owl nation hashtag movie fights live
what's going on everybody we're doing it
it's movie fights and we've got three
awesome fighters and this is kind of a
special edition of movie fights we're
gonna do a little bit of DC themed movie
fights cuz it meant a lot of DC and the
zeitgeist as Henry Cavill gonna stay or
go is Superman big new streaming service
dropping this Saturday Batman day so we
figured yeah let's do a little DC action
and we got some awesome comic-book heads
and just all-around movie fans talk
about it with first up he is a senior
editor at Nerdist and an acclaimed
author and bon vivant Dan Casey welcome
to the party thank you for mentioning my
vaunt activities they've been going
quite bond I really appreciate I know
you very avant ya around font above yes
something like that now we've turned
that phrase into gibberish yes I mean
who can say it ever was anything but
gibberish true with the French maybe yes
Oh Dan thanks for being your brother
thanks second she's no stranger to the
DC Universe in fact you'll be able to
see her on DC daily on the DC Universe
streaming service Clark so much for
having me always great to have you Clark
what's gonna go down on DC daily oh my
gosh so many things talking about things
and we're doing it daily Wow
no we were so there's some so much great
stuff and involved an in-store panels
talking about some of your favorite runs
of comic books old shows new shows we
this we may or may not be discussing the
pilot for the 90s flash and lots of
coverage on news and things like that
but we're really excited to celebrate
Batman Day on Saturday
awesome by the way any truth to the
rumor that it was going to be called DC
talk but then you got sued by the
Christian rock band
okay I just made that up there is a rock
band called DC Talk
last stop and not least up he is the
host of the meaning of podcast and
you've seen him on the Schmo down all
over the place
ace Cabrera yeah thank you for having me
ace thanks for coming in buddy and yeah
what are your feelings about DC talk and
their music I have not heard of DC Talk
what about DC Comics oh I love DC DC is
what I grew up on and hell yeah my
favorite so I'm slightly jealous of
Clark and by slightly I mean a lot yeah
for sure I'm spoiled admittedly like
admittedly I was very lucky to be a part
of that team good times
so I here on movie fights deciding the
fights will be myself and the dance on
the damn cam what up Dan's first up we
have the fact checker extraordinaire and
new movie fights champion once again fan
Merle what up damn few it's less
pressure being over here
by the way how somebody coined a term
for owl nation
the owl nation is started as gaining
some momentum but for the individual
members of Al nation yeah I apologize
don't forget go hooligans who's just
faking I saw that online than I do
hilarious so perhaps that could
collectively be oh yeah faction with an
al Ghul against yeah hashtag go
hooligans yeah um listen by by watching
this program you are now ago who like oh
yes that's awesome I love that Dan can
that's on your belt winning victory last
week yeah and oh she is sent from heaven
above to be the conduit and the voice of
the people
the delightful Danielle Radford so yeah
dan and I will be weighing in with our
votes for the first three questions of
movie fights but there will be a poll
online and Danielle take it away so the
way to the poll will work again there's
always really fun polls if you go to the
movie fights live hashtag on Twitter
please please participate there because
I'll be in there checking for things as
well the only poll that counts is the
one that is on YouTube if you don't know
how this works click down in the
description below feel free to ask us in
the chat we'll all be able to kind of
guide you through that and so when these
two are locked up that poll becomes the
tie-breaking vote so very exciting but
we'll be reading all of your answers no
matter what we do that till the speed
round until I have to actually start
having an opinion which boo town and
then on movie fights live hashtag on
Twitter please please please drop in
there any other answers you have we've
been getting some really interesting
intricate threads that I keep trying to
make sure that I that I point out so
please go ahead and drop those in there
and also you know all your dank memes
yeah sick memes dank memes dope memes
we had some awesome owl stuff we had a
couple weeks ago a great one of someone
put a surfer on joestar's hair joestar's
beautiful wavy hair could hold a surfer
Danielle thank you so much so just a
reminder how our little dog and pony
show works over here the first fighter
to achieve four points wins three
regular round questions then we go to
the speed round and someone can be down
three zip going into the speed round and
take the whole thing with a comeback
victory it's anybody's game you guys
ready to do some damage ready jte
deliver the package
[Music]
Thank You Thor okay we're gonna start
off our DC steamed movie fights with a
DC EU question right here
what DC EU movie most deserves a do-over
now this could be anything from a
casting change a director change a
script change anything you want and
we're not necessarily saying it's a
terrible movie or the movie was a
failure on X Y & Z levels we're just
saying take one of these movies which we
know there's I mean I've gotten a lot of
heat for criticizing like Batman V
Superman for example because you know
they have a strong fan base but so we're
saying okay everything aside it's not
necessarily a terrible movie but what
would you change what movie would you do
something different with do we do over
alright and we will start with player
number one Dan Casey all right folks
Batman V Superman dawn of Justice is a
terrible movie it failed on X Y & Z I
have the solution first of all change
the watermelon I change the Jolly
Rancher to a watermelon who eats a
cherry Jolly Rancher no wonder that
senator didn't want it make the grammys
peach tea scene even longer if you're
gonna go for that level of surrealist
comedy just lean into it really hard
make that like a 20 minute scene but
more importantly ditch doomsday this is
a storyline that you did not earn it's
like how the x-men is trying to do the
Dark Phoenix saga yet again do something
a little lower stakes you can still have
Batman fight against Superman have Lex
Luthor be pulling the to be like sort of
pulling the strings behind the scenes
maybe have Brainiac involved or Oh Mac
or brother I make it about surveillance
so you have the surveillance state where
Batman's worried about this sort of like
larger-than-life alien figure who can
punch through literally anything and
just make it feel a little bit more
grounded so it's something that you've
earned you can still the Wonder Woman
cameo is theirs it's not a bad idea in
concept but the execution was sloppier
than superman snappings odds neck and
Man of Steel
basically also turn up the brightness at
least 50% it is the darkest movie
tonally and literally alright thank you
Dan Clark alright so I have got Suicide
Squad so here's the thing that I think
is the most
interesting about Suicide Squad is that
we all know villains are interesting I
think we're going to be having this
debate in just around her too
but I will save that for then fans are
interested in villains we were compelled
by them they are oftentimes some of the
most fun and interesting and
entertaining characters to watch on
screen in addition to that you do have
David Ayer involved now I feel if we'll
all remember David Ayer wrote the
screenplay for training day which I
would argue is one of the more
interesting explorations of a villain on
screen in recent memory and in addition
to that you have Harley you have the
Joker you have some iconic characters
that are making either reemerging on the
big screen or making their debut on the
big screen all the pieces are there the
tone is what was off for whatever reason
this movie tonally is all over the place
it's not quite funny enough and charming
enough to be to be maybe the lighter
more summer blockbuster fare but it's
also not dark enough and twisted enough
to be that in-depth exploration of
villains and these iconic villains that
I feel like we need and so my argument
is Suicide Squad with most of the pieces
in place but with a big tonal shift
Thank You Clark ace the DC EU movie that
most deserves a do-over is the movie
that was barely finished and that is
Justice League Justice League is a movie
that a lot of people were looking
forward to their entire lives to see the
biggest superhero team-up
of all time finally on the screen with
characters that we actually do know like
Wonder Woman like Superman and in Batman
V Superman we've met these characters
and Ben Affleck's Batman but what we got
instead was the most studio note heavy
movie that we've seen we've got director
miss happenings behind the scenes we got
chaos as far as casting and this movie
truly deserves another chance
and by that chance I mean taking all the
pieces that were already in there and
letting the director complete his vision
and by the director yes I do mean Zack
Snyder and yes I do mean a continuation
of Batman B's
which a lot of people liked and there's
a lot of fans of those movies so I truly
feel like if they embraced that dark
universe that they were going for you
could have gotten the movie that a lot
of fans would appreciate and instead
what we got was the DC Universe trying
to be Marvel and failing completely
gotcha
all right fight it out y'all alright let
me start with Suicide Squad you say that
it needs a tunnel shift but I think
you're under estimating a large part of
the marketplace people that wear gingka
jeans and vapes with googly eyes deserve
to see themselves represented on the big
screen say that Suicide Squad mr. mark
Donnelly is missing the mark from an
argument standpoint and also in terms of
Justice League I think that it was one
of the more successful experiments in
the DCE you it was mercifully brief it
was it struck a tone that hadn't been
seen before you get the elements of
Snyder's darkness but then you get some
of the levity that I think was missing
because these characters look we've seen
Zack Snyder's vision for conservative
lead 5 to 10 years now and it just has
it the some parts didn't make a total
that was worth watching so I think that
they needed to find a happy mint I liked
I was sort of a middle ground and I
think they found that with Justice
League and they're gonna get a do-over
in Justice League to see I you wanted to
take out the best part of Batman V
Superman if you ask fans walking out of
that theater what was your favorite part
they would say for a man what are you
having fun at the end when Wonder Woman
came the first time in the entire fridge
and the score hit and it's Wonder Woman
Batman and Superman fighting to stay
that is a blast and everyone came out of
the movie on a high note because they
remembered that third act being like
well that's a lot of fun because those
are my three favorite characters of all
time finally teaming up and fighting a
big bad villain and that's the fun part
of Batman V Superman and you're taking
out the foot part of no I'm not taking
out the fun part I'm taking out the dumb
part that they're fighting there's no
reason they should be fighting doomsday
and killing Superman in that movie
people left the theater seeing dirt
suddenly rise off of Superman's coffin
after his funeral that's not a high note
that's a horrifying note because he's
gonna rise
or he's a zombie no he's rising again I
don't know I think that boy this is uh
this is very hard to argue in the
current situation Clark's arguments
against these movies well I what was
your thing again no I'm just kidding I
think look at Dan at the end your I
don't disagree free [ __ ] never mind keep
going boys I'll jump in when I'm ready
Suicide Squad didn't hold as much weight
as the Justice League does no Justice
League is one of the most it's the
greatest superhero team-up obviously we
have the Avengers but Justice League
whether it be in the comics whether it
be in the animated series we've seen the
greatness of what can be with the
Justice League and Suicide Squad simply
doesn't have that name recognizable miss
it people don't know what it is the
general audience doesn't know what it is
sure there's a lot of potential there
but a failure in the Suicide Squad is an
acceptable failure and a failure in the
greatest superhero team-up of ever is
not an acceptable failure and to call it
a failure is true because at the end of
the day your movie made 166 million
opening weekend your movie made 132
opening weekend my movie couldn't even
crack 100 and it's the greatest
superhero team-up of all time as much as
critics want to target the DC movies and
say they're bad movies at the end of the
day Batman V Superman has a lot of fans
Suicide Squad has a lot of fans
whereas Justice League the fans didn't
turn out and the critics didn't really
care for it either
it's the biggest failure that we've had
as far as the DCE you go I don't know
about that because I feel like Justice
League you know when we saw Jared Leto
bring the Joker back on the big screen
post Heath Ledger was a huge deal and I
think that whether or not the I think
fans were excited for that no yes the
original pictures the initial pictures
were controversial and the version of
the Joker that they decided to go with
was controversial but in the end when
you are introducing Harley Quinn on
screen for the first time and ranch
reintroducing the Joker with an Academy
Award winning actor I feel like that is
a huge I feel like what happened and
justice Lee was a failure because they
weren't able to really explore the dark
side of these characters and we had to
sort of pivot to a lighter
was it a lighter tone though because
we've had a lot there was some dark
scenes in that movie and there was a
dark scenes with the Joker with Harley
there was hints at an abusive
relationship there was some pretty
pretty dark themes inside Suicide Squad
Amanda Waller was like four savage
inspired babies well I'm saying that I
would push it I think that we need to
push it to the R rating we need to take
these let these DC villains actually be
villains and and even if it wasn't the r
rating it a hard pg-13 is is tonally
where we missed I want to go back to you
saying that I think arguing that Justice
League was a failure and needs a redo is
kind of a flawed premise without redoing
the movies that came before it the
reason that Justice League doesn't work
the same way that the Avengers worked is
because they were trying to make up
eight years of movies in a single film
they were always going to have this be a
loss for them this is meant to be a
platform to showcase these different
characters and then they can spring them
off into bold new directions they were
always sort of batting from behind and
here they can make up some lost ground
so I think that if you want to read your
Justice League the way that you're
talking about it's an impossible task
without redoing the other movies that
came before I disagree if anything it's
a continuation of that task we had Man
of Steel we had Batman V Superman Wonder
Woman all coming in to Justice League
those were the three movies that came
before it and those were the three
movies leading into it what I'm saying
is what's done is done in Man of Steel
if people didn't like it that's fine a
lot of people did what's done is done in
Batman vs Superman if people didn't like
it that's fine a lot of people did what
I'm saying is respect the fans that
actually like Batman V Superman and like
Wonder Woman and like Manistee oh and
want to see a continuation in the tone
and the story of what Zack Snyder
created and he didn't get the chance to
do that because they reach out most of
the movie didn't finish the CGI rush the
product out on the screen that the WB
executives thought that they would like
because it's look it's like Marvel we
can make money like Marvel it's like
know what we came in for was the dark
and gritty Zack Snyder universe and what
we're getting instead is Joss Whedon
taking the handle of this and trying to
do Marvel with DC characters inside a DC
Universe that Zack Snyder created I want
to see the Justice League that Zack
Snyder wanted to make deal oh good the
only thing Justice League deserves to
have redone is to
have paramount flex on them so Henry
Cavill could keep his moustache which
admittedly looked great in Michigan
that's the only thing you should do
that's another reason why we need to do
over the stache was awful it's it's
unbearable you stache gait is real and
I'd love to hear everybody's final
thoughts let's start with Dan go ahead
and make your closing arguments here
look you've heard my opponents I wish
they could redo their arguments but the
answer is clear Batman V Superman was
sort of the linchpin it was the chance
to introduce a larger universe and it
introduced elements but not in the way
that it should have it failed on every
conceivable level but it could have been
salvaged and unfortunately it wasn't and
just proceed to create a sort of domino
effect for the rest of the DCE you I
think that a said it best you know with
the DC EU and the Batman and Superman
and Wonder Woman movies they do have
their fans Man of Steel Batman V
Superman and Justice League but the side
movies is where you can take the more
creative risk and I think that the the
pieces were in place for Suicide Squad
to take those risks and unfortunately
for whatever reason it didn't quite go
one way or the other so that's why
Suicide Squad more than anything clean
break needs to have a redo thank you
Clark
ace Batman V Superman introduced us to a
massive audience and 873 million dollars
is a big win not a failure in my opinion
and also Suicide Squad is a sidequest
movie if anything if it's a failure
that's fine we can accept that and it
also has a lot of fans whereas Justice
League failed at the box office failed
critically and we weren't able to see
the full completion of the DC Universe
what they were trying to do which was
different than Marvel and instead what
we got was a poor imitation of Marvel
thank you alright that's our fight right
there ding ding Dan Murrell facts what's
going on well how we tried yeah I mean
fact is very opinion based round yeah a
whole lot of factual adjustments on my
end so really it's just kind of
listening to the arguments and weighing
my own opinion
to her like that great Dan thank you for
zero facts all right so yeah they're
very Dan's absolutely right on the point
that it was very opinion based and and
just up in varying opinions on the whole
DC EU this was really fun and
fascinating to listen to I just you know
Clark coming from one perspective ace
and then Dan especially ace and Dan
going back on Batman V Superman just
varying opinions there dan very funny
swipes at vapenation and junco genes and
yeah you you definitely had me laughing
the most but I I feel like you're a
black-and-white view of Batman V
Superman discounted a lot of what Ace
was talking about it does have a huge
fan base and you know critics aside
personal tastes aside there's no getting
around that Clark I felt like we were
trying to step carefully around you know
certain points I like the idea of a
hard-r or a darker tone that's r-rated
but at the end of the day ace really
combined just the the technical aspects
of the movie and his passion as a fan
and that really I found that so
compelling just hearing about yeah
wanting to see Justice League this
amazing team up and not just the flaws
of the movie but the disappointment in
that regard ace takes the point from me
dan he's making a face that way I feel
like I feel like everybody had a very
strong basis of their argument dan
obviously was actually Dan and ace and
Clark all three of them were arguing a
very strong base of emotion coming from
different levels so it was kind of a
wash for me on that and so really had to
go for listening to the arguments for
who laid out the best case and I really
do feel like as much as I could feel
dance disdain for Batman V Superman
looking at the question overall I feel
like ace really laid out a very good
case about what had been laid out before
the fact that it was totally different
that it was completely inconsistent that
you know you're fulfilling a vision that
yes it is a very derided group of films
however there are fans out there that
enjoyed it and I that that swayed me so
I'm also gonna have to go with ace all
right ace you take the point and oh and
I do think neglected to mention you had
a box office numbers at your fingertips
I mean are those just in your brain yes
I'm Sophos nerd a little bit impressive
a little bit scary and you know what's
the Internet have to say oh well the 53%
for Justice League Batman V Superman at
30% in Suicide Squad at 16% I would say
of the other ones that people were
recommending overwhelming people want
both Catwoman and Green Lantern to get
another shot oh all right you can remake
Catwoman as long as you keep that
basketballs awesome Thank You Danielle
all right so it is 108 going into
question numero dos whoo ma'am is a good
one
all right so who gives the best
performance in any DC movie ever best
performance in any DC movie ever this is
question number 2 start with player
number 2
Clark all right so here we go I actually
really love this question so as I
mentioned earlier villains are
compelling they're compelling to watch
on screen they're they're compelling for
many many reasons and I know I know
where's my camera here I know what you
guys at home are screaming at your
computer we know I get I am NOT gonna
win you guys I know this but for our
esteemed judges in the room I present to
you Michelle Pfeiffer as Catwoman in
Batman Returns now yes the picture that
we are seeing up here is an iconic image
we all remember how excellent
amazing michelle pfeiffer was once she
got into the cat suit absolutely but the
thing that really stands out to me about
this performance is the true arc that
she experiences if you go back and you
watch Batman Returns you can watch
Michelle Pfeiffer's performance as
Selena Kyle grow and evolve and change
we're talking about real issues that
whether you're super hero super villain
or a regular person or not women
experience she's bullied by her boss she
feels like a failure she feels like a
loser and has this incredible coming
into her own womanhood throughout the
course of this film there's some of the
best acting on display I will cite many
scenes when we get into it I don't wanna
take up too much time here but I would
argue that Michelle Pfeiffer gives the
best performance
maybe not the coolest performance and
maybe not your favorite performance but
she gives the best performance in any DC
movie ever all right all about that fife
life Clark thank you ace before Robert
Downey jr. before Chris Hemsworth before
all these superhero actor icons we had
the very first one and that is
Christopher Reeve Superman now it is
very very difficult to embody a
character that we haven't seen on screen
before and of course we had the
superhero Superman TV show way back in
the day but from everything else that
were going on we're basing it off the
comics and I truly believe that taking a
character from a comic book and acting
that on-screen and giving your own
interpretation of a character it's very
very very difficult to do and he didn't
have a lot to base it on so what we
imagine Superman now when we read a
Superman comic book what we see from
other Superman's that have come in
whether it be Tom Welling or Henry
Cavill is Christopher Reeve that's the
bar we measure everything else on is
Christopher Reeve Superman and I feel
like he embodies the character more than
anyone else Thank You ace background it
down folks I've heard you screaming at
your laptops and your computers and I
gotta tell ya the best performance in
any DC movie ever is Heath Ledger in the
Dark Knight
is a performance that's so good it
killed him it's a performance that's so
good it ruined most DC movies that
followed it they took the wrong notes
from his performance and that movie
which is so defined by Heath Ledger
performance at the Joker he showed us a
side of this Clown Prince of Crime that
we had not seen before he brought a new
darkness a new depth a new complexity to
a character that can often be sort of no
so a little bit Jill be a little bit
murderous but he was weird he was
unsettling he is a wild card in every
scene in which you see him and at the
end of the day he teaches you a valuable
magic trick about hiding your pencil all
right fight it out y'all I feel like
guys at the end of the day what you guys
are arguing for our most iconic
performances when we talk about best
performances when we talk about actual
acting I love Christopher Reeve as
Superman I grew up watching those movies
they are in my DNA but let's be real
two and a half of the four are stinkers
and so I don't think that Christopher
Reeve incredible actor that he was ever
got to really show and really have those
actor moments in in his time as Superman
oh I disagree highly I feel like if
anything Christopher Reeve is is not
just iconic but the performance he gives
is what we relate to as Superman and
when I feel like we talk about DC
performance we're talking about these
characters we're not talking simply
about you know acting but it's acting as
Superman it's acting as the Joker or
Catwoman and I feel like no one acted as
Superman as much as Christopher Reeves
he embodied that character more than
anyone but you might be arguing time and
place because I would say that the
Superman that I think we all know and
love is struggling in the 2000s because
we as a society are having a lot of
problems with masculinity and not
equating violence like I think at the
end of the day Chris Reeve was the right
Superman at the right time and that was
the right time for Superman what we're
struggling with now is is is are all of
those things but I don't know
Sara Lee just because he was right place
right time it doesn't mean that it was
the best performance he was certainly
the best Superman but he's not the best
performance in any DC movie and while
Michelle Pfeiffer gives a great
performance as Catwoman she is also not
the best performer in any DC movie two
words Academy Awards Heath Ledger won
the Oscar for this you said that it like
it's more difficult to portray a
character you haven't seen before
I would argue it's more difficult to
overcome the expectations when people
have so much like attachment to these
characters how hard is it for every
Superman after Christopher Reeves to
stack up to him the same way that Heath
Ledger had to overcome Jack Nicholson
she's a Romero all these people they
grew up with these different characters
they have attachments too but what
you're talking about is redefining a
character which nobody has yet to do
with Chris Reeve but in terms of so yes
I would agree that Heath Ledger
absolutely redefined the Joker for
probably the foreseeable future and yes
you're right he did get an Oscar for
that performance but let's not forget
that that was during a time in the
Academy when people were saying Dark
Knight deserves an Oscar nomination it
was snubbed for Best Picture
it was snubbed in that category which
led to the Academy adding the ten not
the ten Best Picture nominees back so
while I do agree that Heath Ledger is
iconic in that role I think that his
Oscar win in terms of the politics of
the Academy Awards was probably giving a
consolation prize
to the dark night because the Academy
wouldn't pull their heads out of their
asses and actually give it the Best
Picture nomination that it deserves well
before before Heath Ledger's Heath
Ledger's performance we had other dark
and gritty characters we had Ian
McKellen's magneto in the x-men movies
we've we have basis for it I kind of
disagree with what you're saying because
I really do feel like we see we're gonna
have another James Bond we can have we
can have the embrace of saying oh we're
gonna have another James Bond we're
gonna have another Joker if anything I
can go back and take what I like from
certain James Bond's and put that into
my performance Heath Ledger can take
what he like from Jack Nicholson he can
take what he like from Mark Hamill and
say this is what I'm gonna come up with
I'm gonna come up with something new but
he's still taking from it whereas I feel
Christopher Reeves is literally taking
trying to embody a character
that he knows from the comic books and
what people imagine taking from people's
imagination of what a character can be
and he's embodying that character to the
fullest extent
he had 40 years of stories to base that
off of yes he's 39 years of story George
Reeves performance which was a huge hit
and which was iconic at that time so
just because Superman hadn't been on the
big screen he had absolutely been
portrayed in real life different time
period of superhero films now and were
becoming before the air is that you guys
are talking about a very different time
period with superhero superhero films
are now embraced and everyone knows what
superhero performance is whereas
crucifer Reeves it's like there's not a
lot out there it was a gigantic hit of
course it was Oscars so I want to just
throw out there that we've been talking
a lot about superhero movies and we've
been talking a lot about the comic book
aspect of it all and for me the thing
that really stands out the most as
opposed to both of your arguments about
Michelle Pfeiffer as Catwoman and Batman
Returns is that we get to see her inside
the costume and outside of the costume
we get to see the complexities of Selina
Kyle when she is Selina Kyle before the
inciting incident that changes her
character and after on top of when we
get to see her as the villain in the
costume there is a scene in Batman
Returns where and this is the other part
you're her counterpart you know I would
argue that the relationship between
Michael Keaton's Bruce Wayne and
Michelle Pfeiffer's Selina Kyle is the
best portrayal of that relationship
we've ever seen the scene at the
Christmas party at the end of the movie
they're not even in costume and there is
this insanely beautiful exchange between
the two of them where you understand the
whole essence of Batman and whatever
whatever villain he's fighting whether
it is the Joker or whether it is
Catwoman the idea that they know exactly
who the other one is and what are they
gonna do about it and there is real
emotion there is real acting there this
is a scene that could be out of any
tragic love story head and roll this
into your final thoughts Clark so so at
the end of the day I think what michelle
pfeiffer as Catwoman really did really
portrayed and showed us was that we see
the arc we see the before we see the
during and we
see the after we also see the
differences of her inside the costume
and outside the costume we never see
Heath Ledger not be at 11:00 for lack of
a better term and while yes 11 is super
interesting and really fun and super
[ __ ] cool I don't and it is iconic
and yours is iconic I would argue that
there is a difference between iconic and
best and that's why Michelle Pfeiffer as
Catwoman is the best overall performance
in a DC movie
alright thanks Clark ace hit us with
your final thoughts Christopher Reeve
did do two different performances and
that is Clark Kent and Superman and we
get to see this type of performance of
seeing what defines Clark Kent and what
defines Superman and that's the charm
the grace the attitude the kindness that
he shows the strength that he shows and
that is what Superman is that is what we
still see Superman as today and that is
what we saw Superman as back in 1978 we
imagine this type of Superman because of
Christopher Reeves when we imagine other
characters such as the Joker such as
Batman we can have a Michael Keaton we
can have a Heath Ledger we can have a
Jack Nicholson whereas Christopher
Reeves has not been able to be topped
because of how great his performance is
and I do think there is something to say
as far as greatest DC performance and
greatest DC performance is embodying
that character to the full extent and
that is Christopher Reeve Superman Thank
You ace background Dan closing argument
Heath Ledger operates at an 11:00 in the
dark night because it is the highest and
therefore best number what's the word in
front of his Oscar best that's because
he was the best in any DC movie period
folks you talk about how you're gonna
hear all both our characters both
directors we play two different times
the same character you see a bunch of
different shades of Joker within that
movie you see multiple facets of his
madness he challenges Batman he forces
Batman to reconcile with the very core
of his vigilante identity and that is
because of the strength of Heath
Ledger's performance he has made it so
that the Joker is a role that cannot be
attempted by another actor without
impossible amounts of scrutiny more so
than Superman more so than Catwoman more
so than any other
character in all of DC Comics lore time
Wow okay great arguments all around Dan
hit us with the facts and then chimed in
with your decision on this question sure
well one fact I hate hate well I guess
my job is correcting people but it's
George Reeves and Christopher Reeve the
S was dropped alternately on and off
throughout the fight so Christopher
Reeve George Reeves it's one of those
weird things with you everybody's
different
yeah man this is a very I mean if we
could declare a tie we should just do
that but we can't we don't do that
anymore so it's not because that's not
the point of the show to figure out who
won yeah Wow I think that doesn't mean
if you're these are the three I think
maybe Nicholson he might throw in there
as well I think the eisenbergers not
just tonic arguments for but arguments
against I heard that if I'm judging
based on arguments for and against I
think that consistently Clarke was more
consistent both in her arguments for her
choice and against Dan and Asus choices
so I'm gonna have to go with Clarke
based on that I I think that she had the
most well-rounded fight of the three of
them so I'm going with Clarke yeah I am
I agree this is so hard and I feel like
these are the three these are the three
ace yeah you you you hit us with how
hard it was to tackle this character
without as much precedent but I felt
like that I don't know I wasn't as
impressed with that as the criteria and
taking that out of the argument I feel
like there wasn't as much even though I
mean Christopher Reeve was perfect like
he was the man I couldn't imagine anyone
doing it first but just as far as Best
Performance yeah I just didn't feel
swayed it really came down to these two
and yeah I if you asked me off the top
of my head I would say Heath Ledger's
Joker all day every day it's the coolest
I want to be it for Halloween I want to
be it every day I want to quote it every
day I want to just quote it right now
incessantly why so serious I can't help
myself but in the point-by-point
breakdown with specific scenes and
specific qualities in the acting going
by solely the argument alone yeah
Clark you swayed me to Catwoman and yeah
I agree with Dan Marc wolf takes the
point Danielle tell us how much Heath
Ledger was ahead by in the hello
well he's Ledger won by a 50% yeah with
Michelle fight for a 36% and Christopher
Reeve which we wrote as Christopher
Reeves checking robot Danielle and I'm
gonna haunt me you are a spectator of it
I am a fact-checking robit' any other
were there any other choices from the
world wide web well um this one I know
y'all just said because you know I would
appreciate it so I'm gonna go ahead and
say a lot of Arnold Schwarzenegger is
mr. fridge no that was just for me and
you you won and Margot Kidder got a lot
for me was also I mean Margot Kidder is
my Lois Lane yeah oh yes she passed
recently and yes she also I mean those
two I'm it - Christopher Reeve and
Margot Kidder together an iconic screen
duo
well surprised we didn't get any Shaq
for steel got like one or two Shaq's
from steel
Kazaam 69 Shaq is watching movie fights
right now with his burner account in his
hand yeah Dan it pained me not to give
you that point I had the power dance all
day long is this cuz I wrote a book
about Avengers in DC yeah yeah but the
other day I think ultimately I've
disagreed with the choices of the last
two people I gave the points to what
it's about the arguments yep yep but
great arguments all around and that was
not an easy decision to make all right
it's a one for Ace one for Clark dan
looking to get on the board going
through three and question three is okay
so uh
oh the conjurer is that the called the
conjuring verse the controversy
conjuring the universe the nun ruled the
box office last weekend and conjuring
three is still on the table so we asked
what DC character adaptation would make
the best horror movie oh it was a fun
weird question
uh what DC character adaptation would
make the best horror film and we're
gonna start off with player number three
ace when you think horror and you think
DC you think of one character that
embodies this and one character that
literally faces off against hell and
that is John Constantine from DC Comics
created by Alan Moore John Constantine
literally battles demons faces off
against different dimensions and has
horrific encounters with very very dark
themes inside these comic books
especially the Hellblazer comics and the
Hellblazer series it is incredible it is
gritty it is powerful it is disturbing
and that is what we need in a horror
movie
all right thank you ace back around a
Dan what do you like now it was an
unconventional one for this and that is
Hawkman the hero who has been reborn
throughout time because I think you can
tell a really interesting story here he
is the reincarnation aspect constantly
born into a body in a world he doesn't
understand there's the time travel
element you could bring in seeing
Hawkman through
Agis but they tie in like these ancient
Egyptian curses you can really bring
that and have some elements of things
like The Mummy make it love crafty and
lean into those horrible things he's
probably had to encounter alien beings
scarabs all sorts of nightmarish stuff
so it's kind of like an occult Indiana
Jones element but really leaning into
the horror aspect in a way that doesn't
feel trite or hackneyed or has been done
before all right Dan with Hawkman Clark
well I am going with a character that
I've been dying to see on the big screen
and she's friends with John Constantine
and that is Zatanna
so cetana is one of my favorite
characters and all the DC Comics because
for lots of reasons
one of them is there's lots of magic at
play with Zatanna there's death there's
darkness and what I like so much about
and there's the supernatural but what I
like so much about cetana
is that I feel like while I would love
to see her on the big screen in a
Justice League dark adaptation or
hanging out with other members of the
DCU I think that she can stand alone I
think that we could actually have a solo
horror movie adventure starring cetana
and just watch her go and I think those
things would make up have the horror she
already has the horror elements built in
to make a great horror movie so I'm
gonna go as Etana
oh boy three very different answers
fight it out you guys I mean ace I love
you but do I need to say it we've
already seen a Constantine movie and and
it got the R rating and listen by the
way I like Constantine with Keanu it's
fun it's silly it's probably it's not a
great adaptation of course but at the
end of the day we saw it try to make a
bit to them trying to make a dark horror
movie with it and it didn't really work
well here's the thing Clark I mean as
you're working for DC so you know they
have the animated show as well we've had
Matt Ryan play Constantinian in the
series and we've had Keanu Reeves the
reason why this character keeps coming
back is because he's so great obviously
we haven't been able to truly capture
what Alan Moore was doing in the
Hellblazer comics but the reason why he
keeps coming back just like a Batman
Superman just like any other big major
Marvel or DC character is because we
want to see a different interpretation
we want to see the interpretation that
truly disturbs and horrifies you and
that's what we can get from a
Constantine movie everything that we've
talked about now whether it be the
conjuring whether it be hereditary all
these movies taken off babadook that
demonic supernatural eeriness that we
see in these movies these small
independent horror movies are what take
you in and Constantine literally battles
demons how cool would it be to see a
low-budget horror Constantine movie
where he has to battle a demon in a very
psychological disturbing kind of way
that we've seen in these movies that
have had a lot of success I feel like it
will not only be successful but it will
be very compelling and interesting to
see a guy who faces off against demons
battle demons in a much more grounded
sense and not a fantastical sense like a
cetana would be my problem with Satara
is that she's very fantastical and that
she doesn't really have the horror
elements that a Constantine has she's
only called Constantine grounded if
you're a literally Johnny [ __ ] Robbie
that's the only way because he's Johnny
Rotten who uses a Necronomicon to fight
demons he's more like darkly comedic
dealing with the occult in the
supernatural
there is a reason he keeps getting
brought back because they can't get him
right maybe that skis better suited for
a comic book and not a horror movie not
an animated series if you want to go to
reincarnation angle that actually works
why not go with Hawkman do something
that hasn't been done before take a
chance on something that hasn't failed
two and a half times already well I
noticed an in your opening argument you
reference the mummy saying that Hawkman
could be like the mummy and I don't know
if you saw the mummy that came out a
couple of years ago I'm talking about
the Brendan Fraser talking about the
dark universe even that one people have
struggled to get the mummy right how are
you gonna get a Hawkman right not only
that but the fact that Hawkman doesn't
have any horror elements within it where
at least a ton has some horror elements
and Constantine is all horse for me the
question asked horror what would make
the best horror movie and we keep seeing
successive horror movies with demons
like I said before hereditary conjuring
demons are the awful awful thing
you don't want to face off against and I
challenged your point Dan because I
really do feel like making constantine
grounded is the most that idea in itself
should be the greatest idea because how
great would it be to finally take a
character as huge and over-the-top as
Constantine is bring him down to a low
budget and make him face off against
something that is much more personal
much more psychological I think that is
a great great movie that would happen in
a horror franchise chase you should have
picked dr. midnight because like him you
lack vision that is something that we've
seen time and time again you could swap
in any character in any horror movie
over the last 25 years it's been in a
similar demon hunting situation
including Keanu Reeves and you just get
something that we've seen before look so
Tana what she has going for is that she
has not been seen before but neither is
Hawkman in a horror setting this is a
chance to redefine a character that has
been sort of pushed to the side that has
been sort of ridiculed there was a
Hawkman movie in development many many
years ago but it got shelf because they
couldn't crack the code well guess what
I cracked it spooky well does anyone
even want to see a Hawkman affair even
more I'm so glad that you're talking
about girls and horror movies so let's
get back to cetana because at the end of
the day I would love to see a character
like cetana who yes happens to be a
woman on the big screen I think we have
seen a lot of our favorite male
superheroes including Constantine like a
million times get their moment in the
Sun now yes we have not seen Hawkman in
that in that atmosphere yes yet but
speaking to the question of a great
horror movie now I don't profess to know
everything about what makes a great
horror movie but as you all know I am a
huge horror fan and I would argue that
what consistently makes a great horror
movie is characters that you care about
at the center of the scares and that's
why I think that cetana is such a great
choice she is such an emotional
character I every time I read any of her
arcs I care so much about her and so
emotionally invested in her whether it's
her challenges with her father or coming
into her own identity or her own
relationships this is a
character who we are we would be
emotionally invested in the supernatural
the demons the magic that all comes
second in any great horror movie and
that's why is etana is the best choice
I feel like cetana doesn't have that
connection towards the supernatural
elements as much as Constantine does
because for me is Itano as I like
cetanas as well and I feel like she has
that much more traditional magic show
kind of feel and whether that's kind of
the origin of her character as well sure
now in the new DC Comics now she's taken
a much more supernatural tone but cetana
still at the end of the day is simple
magic spells and much more Harry Potter
than a dark and gritty horror movie that
we would get from a Constantine and I at
the end of the day I don't know what
what Hawkman is facing I don't know
what's a ton is facing I know what
Constantine is facing and it's hell on
earth and it's disturbing and it's evil
and it's awful and you talked at the end
of the day about horror movies that
we've seen the reason why these horror
movies are so successful is because
they're good and at the end of the day
people are watching them and demons
people want to see demons on screen and
Constantine has that edge all right I
want to pose a question to the three of
you take a moment think about it who
would you cast as your titular character
and just give me like a two sentence
plot synopsis of your horror film okay
take a moment let's have a little
thinking music okay that's all we can
time we have all right let's start with
ace playing the role of Constantine I'll
have Dan Stevens agent Dan Stevens is a
chameleon he can embody any character
he's already British Constantine is
British already and I feel like he's a
character who already has an edge to him
mm-hmm
and imagine Constantine in a low-budget
horror film were a family that has been
attacked by demons for years throughout
their life and Constantine is coming
into this house and has to have a
personal connection with this family
because like Clarke said a personal
connection with these characters is what
truly makes a great horror movie if we
have that personal connection with
Constantine who has already battled
demons and by battling demons I mean a
psychological turn because when you
battle demons it does have an effect on
your mental state so we have
the mental health aspect as well so
Constantine has to save this family from
a demon that has been tackling it for
years all right Thank You ace background
to Dan the year is 1915 Carter Hall as
portrayed by award-winning actor Oscar
Isaac is plunging into an Egyptian tomb
but what he finds there is more than he
bargained for because he learns an
essential and horrifying truth about
himself he's not who he thought he was
he is doomed to live this cycle of
endless death and rebirth for all
eternity doomed by some sort of sinister
force that he does not understand and
cannot possibly know but he must know
the truth and what he finds down there
is monsters mayhem we see Oscar Isaac as
Hawkman throughout time trying to
overcome this sinister supernatural
force plaguing him so at long last he
can find peace and return to his lady
love
at long last all right thank you Dan
Clark in my Zatanna adaptation the
gorgeous and insanely talented Jemma
Chan is going to be playing the title
role in search okay so the premise is we
there's mystery surrounding them death
the death and disappearance of her
father and she is compelled and of
course her father taught her everything
that she knows and she is carrying on
the mantle so she has to uncover what
has happened to her father and face the
face the hard and scary truths about
what she might find along the way
all right Wow time okay there we have it
what a what a throwdown dan yes facts
where we at that really no not so much
no everyone seemed pretty confident and
clear on their to done they're picked so
no facts to check how great thank you
sir
Wow whoo this is a real nail-biter this
one you all had a lot of interesting
stuff I loved all of your pitches I
would greenlight all of those movies
were rich yeah my green light means
nothing and shoot man I you know what
ace I felt like they hit you a couple of
times on the we've seen Constantine on
the big screen and I felt that took a
little wind out of the sails of the
argument there Clark
you had a lot of good points but I feel
like you know the unconventional choice
of Hawkman I don't know it was weird it
was interesting and then you paint a
picture where it could survive in the
horror genre like I was really doubting
it but that was a compelling film film
and yeah if he if you sent him into that
into those elements in the tomb yeah at
the end of the day this was this is
really a toss-up because you were also
great but Dan swayed me at the end there
also the his doctor midnite slam on ace
was pretty epic so yeah I go Dan this
round Dan Merle yeah all three of those
rounds have been very close very
difficult to judge I think that ace is
pick it made was probably the easiest
fit out of all three of them that I
think at the same time in the arguments
that was kind of something that was a
weakness rather than a strength
particularly because it's been done so
many times so it's between Clark and Dan
for me and going into the pitches I was
you know 5050 but I think that because
in my mind I was waiting to hear like
how is that character gonna fit into the
horror genre this just doesn't seem like
a good fit and Dan actually pitched me a
good idea that that seemed consistent
with the characters seem consistent with
his backstory with with what I know of
Hawkman and he sold me so I'm gonna go
with Dan also dan you and I in lockstep
this whole this whole game yeah let's I
get a room already
okay can't wait to come in and mess it
Danielle what's everybody saying alright
so for the polls we have John
Constantine at 51% Zatanna at 26%
Hawkman at 21% we had some really
interesting things a lot of people I'm
butchering this I'm a reader I don't
hear these things a lot I'm so intrigued
and the demon was one that got a lot
Swamp Thing overwhelming we had in the
chat Jay I want to say this is like
jal123 us said mix pedelec i think that
could be a really interesting horror
movie and then on twitter at Corin
underscore w said it's unconventional
but give us a Batman horror mystery
thriller my Batman is the world's
greatest detective it'd be cool with
someone taking the court of owls and
turning it into gothic horror hashtag
alley-oop I'm also for all of y'all
there is a really good for John
Constantine's 40th birthday he invited
over as a tenant and Swamp Thing and a
bunch of their friends and it's a really
good fun comic so everyone should read
it awesome thank you for the info
Danielle so we're all tied up one that
means we go to a tiebreaker oh yeah this
is truly a great moment in sports okay
so here our tiebreaker rules so you each
of you will give an answer and then you
will argue it a speed round style you'll
each get 20 seconds and then we'll go
back around 10 seconds 10 seconds 10
second robot else
okay and the first person to speak will
answer first second person to speak once
or second third person etc okay you guys
feeling it you're ready to rock time and
then we will chime in with the one who
will not continue on to the speed round
okay we will let you know who will not
continue Dave Batista's MCU future is in
doubt so if he doesn't continue on with
guardians if you were to leave Marvel
who should he play in the DC Universe
bane
okay with bane
I'm going to go with Etrigan the demon
Etrigan the demon and ace
Hades Hades okay Clark answered first
with Vayne she'll get 20 seconds then
Dan then ace
so obviously dave bautista is a big guy
and that's one of the easier ways that
you could associate him with a character
like Bane but I would argue that since
Dave Batista has been really pursuing
acting he has become a really talented
performer I looked to his performance in
something like Hotel Artemus where he
showed a lot of range he showed a lot of
depth and he showed a lot of empathy dan
dave bautista is a mountain range of a
man and he has an incredible range as an
actor which is why I think his build and
his talent would be ideal for Ettrick in
the demon this horrifying hell beast
that speaks in rhyme I think could be a
really fascinating thing we already know
he's accustomed to body pain from
guarding the galaxy so it wouldn't be an
issue for him in that regard but it
would stretch him from what we've seen
before in superhero cinema Bautista of
Hades would as Hades would be the most
compelling because not only would he
faced off against gal gadot as Wonder
Woman which is already a villain in the
Wonder Woman universe he would have a
different take on Hades and finally he
can embody a character that is just pure
evil and not fun and loving like Drax is
he would do something different and it's
the most different from these three
options because as Hades he is just
simply pure evil at the end of the day
with both of these arguments I think
that Dave Batista is he has more range
than maybe you guys are giving him
credit for and I want to see him truly
truly shine and excel in a nuanced
character behind the mask I cared about
him long before that I want to see him
as a bloodthirsty demon fighting evil
and being evil himself having to be
reined in his darkest impulses I think
that'd be fabulous at the end of the day
arrogant a demon still has a fun-loving
character within himself and we've
already seen a Bane with Tom Hardy he
would just get compared to that with
this it's different it's new and it's
pure evil I feel like that's the most
range that he did have oh man you guys
could keep going and go and that was one
of the most satisfying speed
or tiebreaker slash speed rounds that
was great I'm gonna go to Danielle
Radford Oh fine
yeah you know these are really good
arguments I would save it I as much as I
appreciated both the main argument and
the Etrigan argument you were both
essentially making the same argument and
attacking each other for not making the
same argument because you both argued
that it there is range and there is
subtlety
whereas with ace he came at it from the
different angle of it could be more it
could be more evil not necessarily
fun-loving so I'm gonna go with ace just
cuz you guys great arguments but uh yeah
sorry I thought I used to great but he
doesn't move on okay um so I again out
of both of these these are great I I
felt like there wasn't a lot of
listening to each other in this but I
think the Dan had a better argument so
I'm gonna have to go with Clark all
right um and Merle so you pick a sedan
to move forward a standard forward I I
think that everyone had a good basis for
their argument however there were two
competitors that were able to sell both
their actor and their character and
those two for me where Dan and ace I
love Clark's pick but I felt like Clark
your argument was mostly selling me on
Bautista which isn't a bad thing but I
just feel like those two guys really
folded in why they work for that
character specifically and there was
that extra level that for me would
advance those two to the point all right
so it is settled then ace and Dan are
moving on to the speed round Clark you
brought map knowledge and great answers
all day long thank you so much this is
like as far as just like three
competitors 1 1 1 and then that tiebreak
this is one of the closest moving fights
I've ever been privy to Congrats
everybody for just impressive arguments
all around and let's move to the speed
around same rules apply
the tiebreak question 20 seconds 20
seconds the first person to answer will
go first and then 10 second rebuttals
after your twenty second initial answers
dan yes y'all ready for this yes do it
up it up up up okay here is the first
question
wait waited that get us stuck on a copy
right now
sorry Mortal Kombat ok the predator it's
opening this weekend
aside from Batman who has fought them in
comics what DC hero should fight a
predator in a movie well the green arrow
Deathstroke Green Arrow and Deathstroke
okay Dan you spoke first so 20 seconds
begin when you speak now in the comics
Batman has gone up against the predator
before but I think Green Arrow would be
incredible because it would be hunter
vs. hunter it would be truly one of the
fairest combatants for a predator to
face and they were society founded on
fighting the worthiest opponent possible
so naturally if you feel look at
something like Mike grills longbow
hunters arc if you take that version of
Green Arrow put him against a predator
in the jungle or even in an urban
environment you would get what make the
first would make the first predator
movie good is that we had Arnold
Schwarzenegger embodied the greatest
killer on earth the greatest killer in
the DC Comics is Deathstroke and
Deathstroke has the talent whether it be
physically whether it be in weapons to
match the predator and I feel like
that's a much more compelling argument
than simply Green Arrow who has much
more of one weapon which is the bow and
arrow
whereas Deathstroke has the sword the
bow staff
the only sympathetic thing about
Deathstroke is the shade of silver spray
paint they put on Joe Manganiello s
beard Green Arrow is a heroic character
you want to root for Deathstroke as a
character that you want to get beaten by
Teen Titans at the end of the day you
want to see killer versus killer and no
one has the more killer element than
Deathstroke and predator is simply just
the guy to mask as well it's the
ultimate battle that every fan wants to
see and for Green Arrow I feel like
we've already seen
I'm okay you know I feel like it came
down to the rebuttals there for me and
Dan that positing that hero versus the
the viler huntin villain hunter really
swayed me whereas what you were
describing I feel like kind of had that
in sort of a alien versus Predator kinda
way that's you're giving me echoes of
that so I go down on this one even
though it's super close I love listening
you guys talk comics it that was great
Danielle you know it's I much as I
really loved the argument about though
the weapons and the best killer I really
was compelled by the idea of the hunter
versus hunter so I'm yeah I'm gonna have
to go with green arrow on that one all
right Dan Casey takes that one Dan is up
to two one two two one all right
question number two of the speed round
this is a fun one
worst DC villain performance from any DC
movie worst villain performance in any
DC movie oh oh
nigel thornbury whatever his face is
David Thewlis as an ER eats geez I'm
gonna say my least favorite and I'm
sorry Jesse Eisenberg as Lex Luthor
alright
okay so we have David Thewlis from
Wonder Woman versus Jesse Eisenberg from
various DC EU all right Dan you spoke
first 20 seconds begins when you speak
now David Thewlis isn't aggressively bad
as Ares he's sneekly bad it sneaks up on
you in the dead of night wakes you up
from your slumber makes you think what
the entire [ __ ] was he doing with this
character why did they photoshop his
face on that ripped young bod it doesn't
make any sense he's an interesting
character at first but the more you
think about it it's just such lazy
storytelling there they could have done
so much more with this character in the
final reveal Lex
is the most iconic Superman hero there
is he is serious he is powerful he has a
heavy hand in the business and in India
intellectual head as well and Jesse
Eisenberg makes him a cartoon he makes
him Jim Carrey's the Riddler it makes
him a goofy guy who basically can just
make balloons and and and it's one of
those things that Lex Luthor has the
most weight and the most power say what
you will about Jesse Eisenberg but at
least he commits he knew what movie he
was in he's kind of like Eddie Redmayne
and Jupiter ascending he's just swinging
for the fences and damned the results
meanwhile David Thewlis no one cared
about areas in the Wonder Woman movie no
one even knew who Ares was Wonder Woman
took that movie where's Jesse Eisenberg
was overshadowing Ben Affleck and Henry
Cavill in that movie because he was so
freakin bad he was in a completely
different movie time all right
yeah damn a stook that one for me yeah
ace took that one for me we are locked
up at two - man this is great here we go
question number three of the speed round
oh what's the better sequel Batman
Returns or Superman - Batman Returns
Superman - yeah that's the one you got
by default Dan spoke first again so he
will begin the 20 seconds will begin
whenever you speak now Batman Returns is
iconic Clark said it herself earlier
with her argument about why Michelle
Pfeiffer gave the best performance you
can say that about any one of these
characters in there Danny DeVito as the
penguin you get max Shreck Christopher
Walken mad performance his plot is dumb
but the movie stands the test of time
recontextualizing Batman in a way that
we hadn't seen it before a little bit in
Tim Burton's first Batman movie but this
really pushed the envelope and redefined
what we think it's Superman -
Christopher Reeves has more exploration
within his character he's questioning
himself as Superman he's questioned
himself as a being himself because he
sees the different side of a Kryptonian
and the evil that a Kryptonian can bring
in the power that can wield against
humanity so he has to question whether
to value himself or to value humanity
and that is what Superman - brings
within the Christopher Reeve Superman
look if I want to question my humanity
I'll just go to Christmas dinner with my
family if I want to have a good time at
Christmas I'll put on Batman Returns
because it's a Christmas movie takes
place then it takes the cake
it's a super Batman Returns maybe a
Christmas movie but the better sequel is
Superman because you're following up a
character as Superman and to see his
emotional high we get to see the
emotional low and that's what we want to
see in a sequel as we want to see a
character explored at a time okay wow
man both I love both of those movies
Danielle oh I'm good I have to go with
ace for Superman too which hurts me deep
in my face yeah I also I'm gonna go with
ace here I feel like the Christmas movie
did not serve your argument whereas look
you can watch it at Hanukkah too but
yeah you you laid out good points in
your opening argument but yeah you know
if I did the Danny DeVito's penguin is
so creepy and good but yeah ace you had
the better overall take on the film
alright so it is ace with game point
right now okay ace takes this takes the
whole ball of wax dan you need this to
tie them up question for the speed round
what DC character should get a romantic
comedy spinoff
Booster Gold
ace
Lois and Clark
you would take that's two characters you
have one gun sir
Superman yeah okay Booster Gold
and Superman Dan you answer first again
so 20 seconds begin when you speak now
any good romantic comedy focuses on a
protagonist who is so deeply flawed that
prospect of love seems biologically
impossible for them and no one embodies
that more than Booster Gold a reality
star from the future who manufactures
crimes for himself to stop he is the
wisecracking best friend Skeets he has
to go back in time to learn how to be a
hero and learn how to be a human one who
can fall in love Superman and it has the
most iconic relationship which is with
Lois Lane and if anything we want to say
the relationship between the stubborn
and so many quirks that Lois brings and
the much more bumbling and simple Clark
Kent and her realizing that he is
Superman and we can also have conflict
with Wonder Woman coming in because we
know that she brings a relationship with
him as well
I don't think a love triangle between
Lois and Wonder Woman is what you want
to go with for a romantic comedy all we
get from the comedy aspect of those oops
my glasses fell off I'm bad at being a
human he just has to pretend with
Booster Gold you get to see a genuinely
fun no one even knows who Booster Gold
would be close to or what relationship
he would be in whereas Clark we know
it's gonna be with Lois Lane and we know
he has that close ties with Wonder Woman
I feel like that's much more compelling
and then be comedic because we see the
Clark Kent time alright you know what a
started to pick up some ground I thought
Dan laid out in unbeatable salvo in that
in that first answer so I'm going Dan
Danielle I have to agree
yep alright Daniel we're going to the
speed round yes I I will say 200 more to
go
this is a great moment in sports you
guys okay so the winner of this question
takes the whole game which would you
rather have seen more of Brandon rouse
Superman or Val Kilmer's Batman Brenda
Rove Val Kilmer okay so ace you say
Brandon Roth 20 seconds begin when you
speak Brennen railroad a lot of charm in
the first Superman Returns and that's
the biggest thing that we want to see in
Superman if you see him in legends of
tomorrow you see that charm you see that
wittiness you see that happiness that he
brings with in all his characters and I
feel like if he had another chance
within Superman he can still pay tribute
to the Christopher Reeves one and
continue and make something different
within this new era and I feel like you
cannot hold Joel Schumacher against Val
Kilmer he is a great Bruce Wayne he is a
great Batman and have given the chance
in a script that would suit his unique
set of talents he could truly thrive
whereas with Brandon Ralph why do you
want to see that he had to recast him as
a different hero entirely to make it
work you get in that belt
Val Kilmer gave the most unforgettable
Batman performance that we know at least
Brendan Ralph had his fans at least
Brendan Ralph had an image that he was
going for and it paid tribute to that
Christopher Reeves image and look if Val
Kilmer played World of Warcraft people
would be rallying against him with him
as well I think that Val Kilmer was not
he was set up to fail I think there's a
lot more depth there that was not
exposed in that movie and I blame it on
the script and directing Dan Moreau
no kidding yeah man
very difficult however I think at the
end I was won over by Dan so I'm going
with Dan okay um the untapped potential
argument held a little more weight for
me than the living up to the legacy
Reeve wide gotcha you know what I'm
gonna disagree and say ace because I
felt like ace gave us more of what he
liked about the performer about
about that individual playing the
character whereas Dan talked about what
was the odds against val kilmer a little
bit more so ace swayed me so it all
comes down to Daniel Radford both both
really good arguments I do have to say
that the I was blessed sleigh swayed by
the paying tribute argument because to
me that just tells me that you're doing
the same thing that someone else is
already done because again it's paying
tribute so yeah I also have to go with
the untapped potential argument so I
just blanked back in what happened you
won't know God Jesus Wow
what a speed round what a match Dan
congratulations and you all just flexed
a lot of knowledge say yeah you came out
and flexed on him but Dan Congrats I'd
go ahead and plug some stuff and yes say
whatever you feel
I would love to plug my wonderful
competitors honestly like I can't
believe that I'm here right now because
like this was really hard I have a
headache full of blood please check out
a suspense watch Clark on was it was
making out for the meeting of the media
excuse me the meaning of podcast watch
Clark on DC Universe it's gonna be
awesome
you can find me under to some online as
well but don't don't look at me look at
these two amazing competitors I'm so
happy to be here with them thank you so
much
gracious and victory well fought well
for Clark you showed us why you're
hosting a DC show you your knowledge was
incredible and your answers or eloquent
and so much fun please go ahead and tell
us more about upcoming the DC launch and
where we can find you yeah well DC
universes is available on Batman Day
September 15 Saturday and I'm going to
Fantastic Fest next week so I
I will be seeing all the fun Chandra
horror exploitation things big and small
so please go ahead and give me a follow
on Instagram at Clark Wolfe Clark with
an evil from the I'll be doing reactions
no spoilers of course for everything
from Halloween and to little tiny baby
things that maybe you've never heard are
they showing Mandy there they are I
haven't gotten to see it yet so I'm I'm
also like I mean a Nick Cage movie
that's actually getting but yeah buzz
yeah I'm sorry about that Clark thank
you so much
ace you brought it and yeah awesome
stuff fun to listen to all day long
please go ahead and tell us my god to
find me on twitter and instagram at
squad leader ace i talked about anime a
lot a lot about attack on titan and
obviously the meaning of podcast we just
hit episode 50 of the meeting of podcast
like a milestone for us yeah check us
out on the collider podcast youtube
channel as well very cool thank you so
much man ah so good
um Dan Merle where's it where's the belt
currently where's the belt currently yes
I it's in my possession yes that's all
I'll say oh yeah I keep it in a safe
place I polish it yeah you don't want to
let you know you don't want to let like
evil ninjas nowhere know exactly yeah
like I'm gonna tell people where they
can come grab the belt it's safe right
on Dan where can they find you here
every week mostly on twitter at merle
dan on screen jockeys news almost every
morning a nice to you and and as of i
noticed last night yeah you can find me
in Ross corner on Rotten Tomatoes we're
just crazy I didn't know that was gonna
happen
hashtag certified yeah well not quote
yeah sure yeah now I gotta work on
getting my picture on there I don't know
how you do that that's awesome yeah
that's super that's really fun what well
deserved well deserved glad to hear it
brother Daniel Radford thank you for
just being the voice of the people and
chiming in with your own opinions and
deciding the whole damn thing
dan you know yeah please go ahead and
plug some stuff yeah just as per usual
you guys can see me here every Thursday
you can check out my wrestling podcast
tights and fights which comes out on
Thursdays I have open to patreon did the
tears are really small because I know
the worth of y'all listening to me talk
about wrestling and it is $5 capped so
find me on patreon we do some Hangouts
and some other really fun stuff awesome
yeah and I'm Hal Rudnick find me on
Twitter and Instagram at Hal Rudnick if
you are in Los Angeles come to the UCB
theatre on Saturday night this Saturday
the 15th at 11:59 p.m. for the
tournament of nerds we are having our
big tag-team battle show it's going to
be off the charts super fun and again
follow me on all social medias at Hal
Rudnick I want to thank you for watching
I want to thank Billy biz and jte and
the booth and again all of these awesome
fighters I want to go home and just
click on this and watch it again because
our answers are so damn good please tune
in next week thanks for watching movie
fights by night